in questo episodio di tir vorrei
semplicemente parlarvi di un film un
film uscito nel secondo quadrimestre del
2018 che tratta la storia del canaro
pietro de [ __ ] era questo criminale
toelettatore di cani a roma accusato
dell'omicidio di un ex pugile un uomo
problematico che ha passato un sacco di
tempo colpito dai soprusi di giancarlo
ricci fino ad arrivare ad un livello di
esasperazione talmente tanto che lui ad
un certo punto esplode in una nuvola di
odio e rancore e violenza tremenda e
questa quasi fiaba nera ha lasciato il
segno nella memoria delle persone per la
ricostruzione dei fatti da parte del
signor de [ __ ] dove racconta per filo e
per segno tutte le torture che ha fatto
all'ex pugile eco il film prende spunto
da questa storia di cronaca nera ma la
romanza molto per esempio i protagonisti
hanno un nome diverso è ambientato in un
periodo storico diverso perché la storia
originale del 1988
ovviamente essendo ambientata a roma non
vuoi che uno dei due protagonisti sia un
attore che ha fatto anche romanzo
criminale e bayern
il film prima di uscire è stato
presentato dei festival e ed ha anche
vinto dei premi ma voi magari volete
sapere come sia questo film qui beh
diciamo che
in questo episodio di tir vorrei
semplicemente parlarvi di un film un
film uscito nel secondo quadrimestre del
2018 che tratta la storia del canaro
pietro de [ __ ] era questo criminale
toelettatore di cani a roma accusato
dell'omicidio di un ex pugile un uomo
problematico che ha passato un sacco di
tempo colpito dai soprusi di giancarlo
ricci fino ad arrivare ad un livello di
esasperazione talmente tanto che lui ad
un certo punto esplode in una nuvola di
odio e rancore e violenza tremenda e
questa quasi fiaba nera ha lasciato il
segno nella memoria delle persone per la
ricostruzione dei fatti da parte del
signor de [ __ ] dove racconta per filo e
per segno tutte le torture che ha fatto
all'ex pugile
ecco il film prende spunto da questa
storia di cronaca nera ma la romanza
molto per esempio i protagonisti hanno
un nome diverso è ambientato in un
periodo storico diverso perché la storia
originale del 1988
ovviamente essendo ambientata a roma non
vuoi che uno dei due protagonisti sia un
attore che ha fatto anche romanzo
criminale e bayern
il film prima di uscire è stato
presentato dei festival e ed ha anche
vinto dei premi ma voi magari volete
sapere come sia questo fin qui beh
diciamo che vermi tutte cosa succede
questa storia è un po che la volevo
raccontare però mi è sempre sembrata un
po deboluccia perché era cosa un po
stupida che è successa a che mi
affascina moltissimo
tra maggio e giugno a distanza di a
malapena due settimane sono usciti due
film sulla stessa identica storia
italiana io vorrei veramente capire come
sia possibile che in meno di un mese
nell'arte in una finestra temporale
piccolissima dello stesso anno sia
uscito lo stesso film fatto da due
registi diverse e la cosa bella è che
sono i due estremi dello stesso cinema 1
è più elegante metodico l'altro è molto
più d'impatto e molto più sfacciato e la
divisione perfetta del nostro cervello
il cervello sinistro che dice lunga
cosa ho fatto con la mia fotografia
perfetta i miei colori cristalli le
inquadrature che fanno lacrimale gli
altri registi perché su google rogo il
tutto mentre il cervello destro con
rabbia furiosa è
ho fatto mia ho fatto una roba un po
strano in realtà il film è un po una
palla colossale tutta la trequarti di
film ma la parte finale pesce in testa
quello di garrone
sì perché la storia del canaro è molto
più incentrata su quello che il canaro
racconta di aver fatto al suo
persecutore più di più che quello che
effettivamente non gli abbia fatto lui
dice nelle sue testimonianze di avergli
staccato le dita di avergli staccato il
naso di aver staccato le orecchie i
denti di averne addirittura è tolto la
calotta cranica e di avergli fatto uno
shampoo al cervello quindi basandoci su
quella storia che lui racconta per
quanto il mio film di garrone sia
tecnicamente eccelso ed uno dei miei
film preferiti italiani usciti negli
ultimi 15 anni la parte finale è un po
diciamo debole se tu ai rettori racconto
mentre fini stivaletti per quanto sia
una balla colossale da guardare perché è
lentissimo troppo lungo
girato e illuminato come un video di
youtube e non lo dico io lo dice la
gente su internet e comunque andiamoci
piano quelli di youtube la parte gore la
parte violenta finale è quella che
aspettavo perché per chi non lo
conoscesse il regista stivaletti non è
nato come regista è nato come creatore
di effetti speciali
lui ha lavorato alla qualunque ha fatto
fin di lamberto bava michele soavi di
dario argento certo dario argento ha
fatto il cartaio quindi non so se lo
metterei nel curriculum però comunque
come effetti visivi ci siamo poi spunta
fuori che ha fatto il truccatore per
fantaghirò 1 2 3 e 4 ha fatto anche gli
effetti di dvd in the market che è
comunque meglio del cartaio di dario
argento e quando vedo i commenti
negativi e le recensioni negative del
povero rabbia furiosa un po mi viene da
piangere perché mi sa che la gente ha
mancato il punto guardandolo questo film
perché si è lento si è recitato da di
pupazzoni a tratti si è fotografato
malissimo ma è una palese citazione dei
film degli anni 70 80
a partire dal titolo chi si sognerebbe
mai di chiamare il film rabbia furiosa e
questo si nota soprattutto nel climate
del film
la brutale violenza cieca del
protagonista purtroppo non posso spalle
arvelo sia perché non posso poi più
monetizzare il video sia perché vorrei
che lo vedeste da con i vostri occhi
ma secondo me ne vale la pena anche solo
per avere due punti di vista usciti
nello stesso anno a ridosso di due
settimane della stessa identica storia
italiana quanto cazzo mi fa ridere
questa cosa